salman khan is here he is the founder of
khan academy the online learning tool
that has reached and taught millions
forbes magazine calls it the largest
school in the world bill gates calls him
a true pioneer khan academy's goal is to
provide a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere
solomon khan has written a book
describing how such a vision might be
achieved it is called the one world
schoolhouse education reimagined i am
pleased to have him back on this program
welcome great to be here when you were
here we talked about how this whole
thing started for you and the
development with your niece i think who
was down in louisiana and you were
teaching her and you use youtube and and
all of that um
where is it now yeah you know it's since
i think when we last spoke i think it's
about 18 months ago
i think we were reaching on the order of
about a million students every month
we're now at 6 million students every
month
the team has grown i think when we last
talked it was a five-person team we're
now uh we're approaching 40 people and
it's really about um not just the videos
although the videos are still a big part
of what we do i'm not the only person
making videos anymore
we were not translating the videos into
every major language in the world
our software platform is being used in
classrooms and outside of classrooms
around the world uh
um yeah so it's kind of uh it's it's
just where it was before but just you
know maybe ten times bigger you think
you were born to teach
uh i i enjoy it
i wasn't born to play basketball
but in fact you did have passion for it
you had a a technique for it uh i mean
and you found more love for it than you
did being obviously because you left
being you know in the you're in the
hedge fund world
yeah no i mean the one although you know
it's most people don't realize the
commonality between what i was doing
before and what i what i hope i'm doing
now and even at the hedge fund world uh
it was actually an intellectually
intriguing job in some ways it wasn't
that different what you're doing now is
what you you have to context switch from
one space to another you're constantly
learning you get to talk to a lot of
people to learn from them and so for me
a big fun part of that job was i always
got to learn stuff i couldn't
communicate as much as i might have
wanted to uh and now i get to get the
chance to do both and where can you take
this
you know a couple of things that we're
working on i mentioned we're translating
the videos but we're also
internationalizing the entire site and
we already have partners of the carl
slim foundation in latin america the
lemon foundation in brazil
we recently took a trip down to brazil
and you know there was national interest
the president had asked what are we
going to be able to do together
brazil in brazil in brazil so um
i think in the next year you're going to
see khan academy going global in a much
more significant way i think you're
going to see
you know it started with videos we've
had an online component exercises we can
give people feedback on where they are
but we're going to make that much much
more serious you've had this you know
the 48 states have adopted the common
core standards there aren't any
assessments out there there's some
groups out there that are going to be
developing assessments
and and through this whole transition
you're going to have teachers and
parents and students wondering about how
do they navigate the switch and what we
hope to do is have really take our
exercises and turn them into really
rigorous assessments so that you can go
to the site get a really strong
diagnostic of what you know and what you
don't know so we can narrow you in on
hey here's what you need to work on we
can kind of coach you through that
process the tools for the teachers will
get better and and we also want to
figure out a way for you to get credit
for
for what you know how far away are you
from that
we've had a lot of interesting
conversations uh you know it's the
resistance you know they're surprisingly
you know maybe we're just not seeing the
resistance because we're not that that
far along yet but
uh you know especially if you talk about
some of the core college courses or the
late high school courses the things you
know right now you have 75 70 of
students who go to community college
have to take remedial math and they
usually don't find that out until they
show up and start paying tuition and
this is something that no one wants to
happen they want these and it's the
biggest predictor of whether they're
going to be able to finish or not and so
if we can address that so ahead of time
someone can show look i know my algebra
i know my pre-algebra i know my
trigonometry i'm ready to engage
if someone can prove that even at the
professional level hey i can program a
computer you know i might not have the
four-year degree but i'm employable
we think that could have huge
implications for
one someone who doesn't have a chance to
go to traditional university or even
kind of some of the structural
unemployment issues we think it's
structural unemployment there's a skills
gap but we think it's even more
signaling gap that signaling
signaling gap that you have people who
actually do have skills and there's no
way for them to prove it uh right now
where we have that problem where people
are learning stuff on khan academy
and they want to prove it to the world
but there's no way for them to prove it
they know something that they know
something whether it's we have
accounting videos some kind you can
actually learn accounting at a pretty
decent level uh you know we have a lot
more to do but um there's no way for
them to validate that and and so we
imagine a world where uh you know a few
years out someone will be who would set
the standard
you know i think for any type of
credential uh the key is who's going to
be the consumer of the credential who
does it matter to and so for someone
wanting to prove that they know algebra
i see well we have to we have to go to
universities and make sure that you feel
that this is a credible standard that
someone has attained but if you're
talking about if you're talking about to
someone on a program or does someone
have good critical thinking skills or
does someone write well i think you go
straight to the employers and say would
you respect this type of a
of a credential and you know the thing
we point out is even today very
expensive credentials have have limited
information in them and that you could
go to a fancy university and when you
know a company like google or microsoft
interviews you they still assume very
little they make you go through a very
you know the first interview is you know
go write bubble sort on on the white
board which is what you typically learn
like the first three weeks of computer
science class and this is someone who's
gone through four years and so to some
degree if you could take that process
and turn it into a credential and tell
the rest of the world like you don't
have to go to a fancy university but if
you can get to this threshold you get to
round three of the interview process at
software company x or bank x or uh
fortune 500 company y why
it could it could be a powerful thing
this is not a silver bullet but there is
some magic here i mean what is it that
you understood about learning when you
taught your niece way back when
yeah and i'll emphasize it's not it's
not a silver bullet
the biggest criticism we get is like
this is not a silver bus like i agree
and and and you know and and and
well
but in other words what i mean by that
but there there's there's no easy way
here you're just helping people learn
better right we're helping people learn
learn themselves they teach themselves
to learn and that's the key and that's
what we always want to point out is that
for us and for me to really educate
someone doesn't mean to try to pour
information into their brain and hope
that they can regurgitate it out is to
really allow them give them the tools so
that they can take agency over their own
learning and you know we all say that's
the real skill yeah if you can factor a
polynomial that's nice but if you can go
out into the workforce and some new
technology emerges or some new issue
comes and you can take ownership of it
and learn it that's that's what you want
people to be at and and and so what i
think what we tapped into and you know
initially was me making stuff for my
cousins is
put stuff out there that's that's that
respects the learner that's approachable
that's conversational that really gives
people the thinking behind something not
just the formula
and you let them access it at their own
on their own terms and uh there's
there's there's huge need for that can
you monetize this
so uh it's an interesting question i you
know we're not for profit so uh that
means you know no one owns khan academy
but still we have to sustain ourselves
in in some way and uh not-for-profit
doesn't mean that you can't generate
revenue i mean
universities do that quite well
they're uh
i i i think but on top of being a
not-for-profit we have in our mission
statement a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere so we've kind of
limited ourselves in terms of we're not
going to charge we're we're committed to
not charging for the learning part
um so so far we're philanthropically
supported
and hopefully i can always make that
case that there's there's no
it's hard to have a more scalable social
roi return on investment um
but we are discovering that we've
inadvertently built a brand and with
that brand we are starting to license
the content we're starting to just do
some brand partnerships people start
hearing more about that in the next
couple of months that are actually
helping pay for a significant amount of
our of our of our operating budget about
corporate america or corporate world
yeah and that's i think there's a
there's a few training in their
workforce is a crucial ingredient yes
yes and so there's two elements of that
one is a lot of corporations feel that
they're not able to find the talent that
they need to fill certain slots um and
so we can either help the world ramp up
with those skills and then help prove
that they know those skills and then i
think what you're looking to is this
idea of like look even in corporate
training itself this whole self-paced
model makes a lot more sense you're
sitting at your desk you want to improve
your skills in one vertical or another
you do it at your own time and pace so
it is something we have talked to some
people about corporate training uh a lot
of corporations are starting to realize
that the the best thing they can do for
their customers is educate their
customers about the domain that they're
in and so we're starting to do stuff
there as well why'd you call this the
one world schoolhouse
you know it's funny because i i
i this was the working title at first
and uh the and it was working because i
always say oh it's like well it's the
irony is a lot of what we're talking
about is going back to the one room
schoolhouse where you have multi-age
classrooms much more interactive kids
taking agency responsibility for each
other
and they was like yeah but there's some
neat things here where like anyone any
any kid in the world can access this we
can connect any student in the world
there's another element to it which i
talk about you know it's i want to take
the lecture off the table in the
classroom so the classroom can engage
with the world in a more relevant way uh
so yeah it just sounded kind of a fun
sort of one-room school house one world
okay but that goes to the core of here
and i really am interested in in the
experience from the learner's standpoint
i mean obviously you the part of your
notion is that what we understood you
know as the classroom
method of teaching
is not preordained as the best way to
teach
absolutely i mean if you go back
400 years ago and you saw the the few
people who were getting an education 400
years ago it was pretty much private
tutor and private tutor was self-paced
hey you master concept now let me show
you master's crucial mastery is crucial
i mean if you don't if you don't master
pre-algebra it's kind of nuts to expect
you to understand algebra or or but we
do it we're right now you can you can
barely pass algebra and they're going to
stick in algebra
and uh and and and and what happened is
about 200 years i go into the history a
bit in the book uh about a little over
200 years ago the prussians you know
now part of or somewhat part of germany
uh were the first to say well we want a
a large labor force and this is the
beginning of the industrial revolution
let's have universal public education
it's actually a pretty profound thing
that they did but they say how do we do
it in a economical way they said well
maybe we batch students together i mean
you know we see how some of these
factories are starting to get built how
do they do things at scale we batch
students together moving moving them
align at a set pace
we try to pour knowledge into their
heads some kids it'll stick some it
won't at some point we start
sit you know we we start sorting the
oranges you know these kids are going to
be juiced and these kids are going to go
to whole foods
but um
you know so
and there was an element of even
even the old prussian model of some
degree of indoctrination um and then in
the mid-1800s the u.s uh
you know famously said well we want to
have universal public engineering that's
no coincidence so we based it on the
prussian model we based it on the
prussian model the japanese too it's no
coincidence these are the these are the
industrial superpowers that emerged
because they had a middle class that was
educated uh but they fundamentally
didn't rethink the model a lot of people
you know i talked about in the book it
was actually discovery to me when i was
doing some of the research uh you you
know i was like why do they always teach
physics in the 12th grade why do they
teach chemistry in the 11th grade why
did they have where did this come from
and it came from literally a group of 10
men about 120 years ago you know before
the internet or dna or anything that
said people should learn geometry in the
10th grade people should learn they
should have three years of english they
should have and it was just and it
hasn't changed it's pretty much frozen
there and so what we're saying is
a lot of the ideas aren't new let's
master a concept let's personalize the
instruction to the student this is what
would have been the the gold standard
300 years ago and even 50 years ago if
you said what's the best well a
personalized instruction now could you
do that for every student
no it's very expensive it would cost you
you'd have to hire a teacher for every
student
and what's interesting about technology
is now we can go through the same
thought experiment and say well maybe we
can do personalized instruction for
every student if we rethink the role of
the teacher if we move them up the value
chain instead of them just being a
lecturer we let them see data on where
every student is every student is going
at their own pace mastering concepts we
leverage the fact that the students can
teach each other this is where kind of
the one room schoolhouse comes in and
that's another kind of meta-level skill
that i think is lost today yeah it's
nice to be able to factor a polynomial
but the ability to take leadership and
the ability to actually manage your your
peers if you're a 16 year old
you're now leading some 12 year olds
you're you're teaching them things uh
can we start to leverage in that way and
so uh everything we're writing here is
like yeah i think we can i and we're not
only can we but we're doing it we're
seeing it and and you know khan academy
is a part of it but we're able to work
with schools today that are actually
experimenting here you also say that
face time should be separate it's a
separate thing from mastery of concepts
yeah you know i mean right now face time
and seat time whatever you want to call
it is it's there people sit i mean at
the university level so the point that
your units are called they're literally
seat time units three credit hours six
credit hours it's how many how many
hours you sat in a chair
um and what we're saying is look what
one should go to a competency model
where it's not how how long you sat in
the sat in the chair but did you learn
the material at a level of mastery and
whether it took you whether it took you
five days to do it or five years to do
it that's irrelevant you you got to that
level uh the other is when you get human
beings in together in a room you know a
lot of people say hey but you know
this video lecture stuff you know i
enjoy it but i loved my college lectures
where i could ask a question and i'm
like that's exactly the point instead of
questions being five percent of the time
it should be 100 of the time there
should be none of the students just
sitting passive and you know what i
point whether you have 10 students in
the room 20 students in the room or 2
000 students in the room if you're
having a passive lecture it doesn't
matter there's no interactivity and
we've all sat in a college lecture or
even in high school and we're all in the
room together but we're not able to talk
to each other it's actually incredibly
dehumanizing that you're getting no
interactivity and so what we're saying
is a lot of your your exposure to the
concepts and and once again humanities
have been doing this for a long time go
read the chapter and we're going to
discuss it when we come to class we're
going to have an interactive thing so so
what's the difference
or why students feel
more passionate about their sports
coaches than they do about their math
teachers
yes and so now this is something that i
feel strong because i you know i i saw
it in high school you're in 10th grade
algebra class the teacher asks the
students to do like six problems they're
like oh my god you know they're groaning
and they're like oh this is the meanest
guy on the planet and then like three
hours later we're in like wrestling
practice and and the teacher says
i want you to do 50 push-ups followed by
running three miles followed by another
50 push-ups and they're like yes sir yes
sir push me harder i want to i want to
collapse i mean literally sometimes
people would collapse they're working so
they're willing to work so differently
and the difference is that they feel
that the coach is on their side that the
coach is preparing them for
that in their interest to do what he
said they're interested they're training
me well the unfortunate thing is even
though the math teacher
cares just as much or more about the
student the math teacher is viewed as an
adversary hey this is the person who's
going to keep me from passing this is
the person who's trying to flunk even
though that's not what the motivations
of the teacher are and so what
we're advocating what we're seeing is
working well and the teachers we've
worked with really love it is look
become that coach and and don't you
don't have to become the both the
assessor and and the lecturer and the
coach be that coach figure be that
mentor you'll form a deeper connection
with the students and you're preparing
them for an outside world it's just it's
a very subtle but powerful mindset
you're a pathway to excellence exactly
that's you know it's funny i had a uh a
a dinner i happened to be sitting next
to wendy kopp teach for america
and and i we just randomly started
talking about you know what do you
notice amongst the teach for america
teachers that are really able to to move
the dial and she says you know it's
actually surprising most people think it
would be about content delivery who can
give the best lecture and who could it
who has magic as a teacher yeah and and
you know because movies try to
and they do have magic but it's a
different type of match it's the
teachers who can who can change the
students mindsets who can be that older
brother or that father or that mother
figure and say look this is this is a do
or die situation if you want to be able
to survive in this world
i'm here for you but it's your decision
to make it's the same type of psychology
that i think a good coach does
and those are the ones that once you get
the student once it clicks in there wait
i have to take ownership here if you're
on a football team you got to learn the
plays exactly you know you have to take
ownership for yourself exactly look i'm
it's not me it's you you're going to
make it or you're not and i'm just here
to help you and that changes that i
can't play the game for you you have to
play exactly exactly exactly so when you
look at the next five years where might
i see com khan academy in five years i
mean is it simply a multiplier effect of
how many kids you can reach
it's definitely that so in five years i
mean i hope we're reaching you know 50
who knows what might happen with
internationalization i hope that you see
especially even in places where they
don't have access although i think the
access issue is going to get solved to a
large degree in the next five years with
cheaper tablets and and more internet
um but throughout education throughout
education throughout education but even
outside of formal education systems p
ngos are going to be able to give
tablets to kids right right um
i i i think it'll be some of the ideas
in the book that um right now like hey
we know more lectures in classrooms
i think they're going to start being
mainstream i think you're going to start
seeing top institutions realize that
it's in their best interest to not
define themselves by hey i gave a good
lecture that's passive but what's the
the formal experience that i do on my
campus and i think when you do that when
people realize that it's not an either
or that these are tools that will help
students take ownership but then it
frees up the physical environment to go
deeper
i think i think that'll be a mainstream
thing in five years where are we in
terms of online education
if in the evolution because it didn't
deliver what many people thought it
would once they understood it could be a
tool
yes and i think yeah you had a first
wave in like the late 90s early 2000s
right it was kind of obvious the
internet's about disseminating
information maybe education it came
along with the development pc i assume
that's right well the pc i mean steve
jobs famously originally thought that
the the the personal computer was going
to be a treadmill for the brain right he
thought that was the killer app for the
computer yeah it ended up being for
other things and i mean obviously it
helped people learn as well but it
didn't really hit the nail on the head
there then with the internet i mean even
pre-computer the radio people thought
was going to be the killer app for
education they thought
tv vcr these are all hey put the light
tv shares on demand now right
we can uh
i i think what happened in kind of maybe
about six five six years ago i mean you
can't underestimate youtube's power here
where it really lowered the cost of
streaming video of producing and
streaming video close to zero to the
point that a guy in his closet could
start making it for his cousins and it's
that's you that was that was me and and
start getting traction um and i think
that helped um kind of show people that
look there's a demand here and not just
for the videos but for the whole
interactive immersion immersive
experience and so this past year you've
had these moocs emerge these massively
open online courses harvard and mit edx
there's a group from stanford other
folks who have been doing it and and
what really seems to have credit
right now for the most part they're
issuing certificates although they are
starting to to partner with a few
institutions for credit as well and so
it's really different this time is in is
it looks like all of the players
including us are looking at how do we
systemically become important to the
system what are if we with a blank slate
what is the whole point of education
what is the whole point of a credential
and how do we do that in the best
possible way
either outside of the system or in
partnership with it thank you great to
see you great to be here the one world
schoolhouse education reimagined
salman khan ben of the khan academy
thank you again thank you for joining us
see you next time